CS2 is basically for all intents and
purposes in open beta
sort of The Limited Test is now
available for anyone who has prime a
rank and is situated in a region where
it's available the new Inferno is here
new matchmaking and with it mr12
let's talk about it
[Music]
okay so before we get into the
nitty-gritty of it I just wanted to let
all of you lovely Counter-Strike fans
know we have a Facebook Clan and yes it
will switch over to CS2 that's right you
can pug with me your friends and other
members of our community whilst climbing
the leaderboards and winning points to
spend in the shop it's totally free to
join so check out the link in the
description below and start fragging so
yeah
CS2 late last week valve pushed an
update making it so that virtually
everyone can get a CS2 invite all you
need is prime an active Rank and to be
in a region where it's available I
didn't have a rank obviously because
it's matchmaking so I had to to play
against and
a blatant cheater to get one and that I
still didn't get access until a full day
later and then finally I was led into a
beta that has been around for nearly
half a year call me salty or whatever
the you want but I still have
friends who are Global have 5K Plus
hours and have been playing this game
since 2013 and then 1.6 in stores before
that who still don't have access I'm
just gonna say it this whole thing sort
of really really exhausting and I don't
know why valve opted to do it this way
say what you will about valorent when
they release the beta at least you could
play it anyway enough whining let's talk
about CS2 for starters the game feels
weird hitreg feels way better than CS go
but the movement is still still and
spraying continues to feel like absolute
dog and I often feel as if I'm
losing Targets in the midst of a pull
down deagles and indeed pistols at large
feel fantastic but I swear to God man
there's something off about the opping
and I I just can't put my finger on it
part of it is probably due to the fact
that you still can't turn off the view
model Bob which for those who don't know
does affect the sway of your scope but
it also just sometimes feels kind of
valorenty where like you see a smoke
trail go through a body and somehow it
just didn't hit them things like lag and
tick rate and the overall net code
continue to feel sort of bad but those
are the things that valve will iron out
over time all in all I think the CS2
beta is in a really good place way
better of a place than CS go was at this
stage the only thing that I would really
like for them to revert is the removal
of an alias jump bun there is a way to
implement one by the way which I learned
from this video by The Almighty nart but
yes still need to release left click
when you use it and overall it's just
kind of cumbersome I understand why
valve are trying to clean up the
obtuseness of utility usage in
Counter-Strike I do and I fully support
it
but it does kind of feel like this is a
step too far like this is something that
we have become accustomed to over years
and it really doesn't take a lot away
from the Casual player base to just let
us have it as far as Inferno goes
all right let's talk about it many of
you are probably aware that I regard
Inferno in very very low esteem and
think it is by far the most dog map
in active duty and that it isn't even
close most people don't agree of course
and have been Stockholm syndromed into
thinking that it is the quote-unquote
ultimate decider map but as Aristotle
once said there is quite simply no
accounting for Taste the point is that
when I heard that valve were fully
reworking the worst map in competitive I
was psyched I was so excited I genuinely
couldn't believe it
and then I loaded onto it it's the same
it's exactly the same it's way way
prettier hats off to them for that it is
gorgeous but it is exactly the
same except now you need to just relearn
all the smokes now in my opinion they
could have used this as an opportunity
to just open up bottom team it a little
bit maybe give ultimate a little bit
more value for the teas
but alas people really seem to like this
stupid map and so we're stuck
with it forever as for the new
matchmaking it's really cool I've only
played a handful of matches but so far
it's been pretty great I do wish your CS
go rank had a little bit more of a
bearing on your CS2 starting point in
the placement since it does seem like a
lot of us are smurfing a little bit but
it's really cool that there's something
to play for in matchmaking again there
is one thing that I would change and
that is this whole permap rating thing
please valve do not introduce that like
pardon the abrasiveness but that is a
really stupid idea perhaps the biggest
problem with counter-strike's current
pug culture is that people only play
three Maps the fact that you
could pick what map you wanted to play
in ranked in CS go it was already
extremely stupid and now they're just
propagating the issue they should have
taken this as an opportunity to just
make it Premiere only they're missing
their chance in my opinion to force the
player base to improve at every map
instead of just wide swinging out of a
ramp until they hit Global speaking of
mm valve you the new mm experience as an
excuse to shorten things from mr15 to
mr12 and presumably the Esports scene
will follow suit which has caused a
little bit of controversy for those who
don't know mr12 which stands for maximum
rounds 12 is simply a round structure in
which there are 12 rounds in half it is
the structure around which valorent is
currently built and the structure around
which Counter-Strike used to be built
that's right mr12 actually goes all the
way back to the days of 1.6 it wasn't
until much later that valve switched
things over to mr15 so while it is true
in a sense that CS2 is copying valorent
it's also bringing Counter-Strike back
to its roots the question is whether
that's a good thing for starters why
would valve want to introduce mr12 in
the first place well the answer is
presumably to make matches shorter since
in go they could definitely run a little
long what isn't necessarily obvious is
whether switching to mr12 is the best
way to rectify counter-strike's match
length issue valve could shorten bomb
timers smoke timers freeze time round
time
Etc speaking of time I have long said
that one of the biggest problems with
counter-strike's match length issue
stems from overtime CS go over times
are way too long man and I don't just
mean at the pro level the number of
times that I've run a face at pug that
has run into quadruple or quintuple over
time and just found myself in a place of
look I'm a really competitive person but
I don't have time for this it is 25 ELO
my dude not the major and even
if it is the major no single map should
run two and a half hours that is patent
lunacy case in points that time liquid
played Mohs in the group stage of IEM
cologne 2021 their Inferno about went
nearly 60 rounds and lasted in around 2
hours and 20 minutes it was also the
third map in a bo3 which means that a
single group stage matchup lasted over
four hours I think we can all agree that
that's too much if valve could just
rejig how overtime works or at the very
least just lessen the amount of money
you get it could both help to move
ranked matches along and shorten those
Eternal Barn burners that just drag a
broadcast on hours longer than intended
all that said I don't actually have any
sort of prejudice against mr12 I think
it could work and I've actually been
enjoying it so far I just think there
are other things that valve are going to
have to adjust long term in order for it
to be feasible namely the economy the
reason that mr12 works in Valor end is
because of way things like weapon prices
kill rewards and loss bonuses are
structured in valorant guns are both
cheaper and stronger utility carries
over when you die and the most you'll
ever have to do is a single save whereas
in CS go double saves are a thing for
those who aren't familiar with the term
there are times in CS go when you are so
poor that even a full unmitigated say
wave isn't enough to guarantee a Buy in
the next round so what you do is force a
shitty buy save the next round and then
finally buy the round after that hence
the term double save I haven't yet had
the displeasure but imagine playing CT
Inferno with the current economy on mr12
I feel like teams would start saving
when one person dies hell they'd start
saving if they loaded in and they found
that the spawns weren't to their liking
the worry is that switching to a shorter
round structure might make it harder for
better teams to emerge Victorious pistol
rounds already carry a ton of weight in
CS and as robs rightly observed an
unmitigated switch to mr12 could yield
random results long term uh I think I
dislike it as well
but if people want to try it I don't
care
I think it's
gonna be even more random results
now again this doesn't mean that valve
can't give the whole mr12 thing a fair
shake it really could be better for
Counter-Strike long term I just think
there's certain adjustments they're
gonna have to make in order for it to be
feasible what those adjustments are is
hard to say and there hasn't been a ton
of indication as to what they might be
the obvious answer is to rejig loss
bonus and that might work but we won't
really know what the best solution is
until we start experimenting that said I
trust that valve are willing to
experiment to listen to feedback and see
what sticks I just hope that we as a
community are as well I know a lot of
you seem to be against mr12 from the
get-go but I would really encourage you
to just give it a chance for the sake of
bettering Counter-Strike as a whole we
really won't know if it's the best way
to play the game until we put it through
the ringer so yeah put it through the
ringer go play it unless of course you
can play CS2 in which case you should
probably just go give your attention to
something that wants it
because technically like when is the
last day of summer technically September
23rd right technically for the next
three-ish weeks it's not a lie to say
summer 2023 but if they wait Beyond
right but if they wait Beyond September
23rd then it becomes a lie then they've
set a public deadline that they didn't
meet what I liked is that they said that
to avoid this exact situation to avoid
missing a deadline they said an entire
season it's at an entire quarter of the
year yeah I know right and they still
might miss it